good afternoon and -- welcome
to aging and long term care we
only have -- one bill to be
presenting and it does enjoy
a to pass -- by the committee
-- so why don't we start
by establishing a quorum
six Calderon please variant
present you
Kalra lackey here
five hi
hi quorum is been established
welcome everyone to the hearing
-- for the committee on aging
and long term care and welcome
committee members I will go
ahead and present and turn over
the gavel to -- the vice chair
and I will keep it
brief thank you ever
sorry this item number one
A. B. eleven thirty six
assembly member in this area
you may begin Sir thank you
as a component of the master
plan for aging AB eleven thirty
six replaces the department
of aging within the department
of community living that would
provide Courtney that leadership
and addresses the needs of
older adults with his abilities
and care givers California
department of aging has that was
established as the state and see
responsible for administration
of the programs provided
by the older Californians
who CA authorized helpfully
specific program certain
folder adults in their homes
and communities in addition
to the California department
of aging the department state
department of health care
services the department of
rehabilitation and the state
department of social services
are responsible for delivering a
range of services to California
shoulder adults and people with
disabilities often reduplication
and without administrative
efficiency so with that I
will keep it short and invite
witnesses Herald count for
from C. for a and Christian
mills -- from California
independent living centers to
-- offer brief thoughts so
that we can now move forward
thank you
I'll give the short version also
California's long term care
system it's a piecemeal approach
studies after studies have
indicated that there over
thirty five her grandson five
search holder people with
disabilities pardon me
Sir if I may here --
I believe we have quite a bit
of support for this absolutely
would you have any objection
Mister Nazarian of Colin role
-- -- if the jury decides
to do it I I and I am happy
to see it we voted upon
which you had
so okay so we have a
motion from assemblymember
Reyes and second of by
assembly member Rubio
-- anyone in opposition
is there anyone in support
any comments from committee that
all right members
committee members very
well please call the roll
maybe eleven thirty
six Nazarian five zero
five Voepel hi Voepel
Warner hold off right
Kalra I Kalra five
ninety five ninety
five minus aye Rubio aye
is there anyone else in
the vote we have to hold
on that's it
okay
the cell
the bank gap right with that
we turn our meeting thank you